[Musique]
t'écoutes un truc comme ça tu commences
à faire chez un bon gros ballons des
amis là je suis à deux doigts je chante
je termine là à la libertine et ses
semblables jamais diversification des
écouteurs comme les erp a eu lieu le
saut est bon cela dit le sort est bon ah
si c'est bien quand on attend des choses
pas top serait qu'un super son art si
c'est bien ce qui pour finir mais elle
chante pas que ça bref et écoute sur toi
d'ailleurs les lecteurs ça me faisait de
m'insulter oui pour une peinture de
couture gueule et quelques claques le
buso ça c'est très bien ça me fait du
bien moi ça me fait des vacances surtout
allez on s'en va à créteil bons d'achat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous
à
les deux divas lbo lundi en cours
[Musique]
bravo
lui m'a
berne chez moi je les tournées
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
avant j'étais grosse mama j'ai déjà
c'est le résultat n'est pas ce lien et
chic à perdre énormément la douleur
franchement je sais mais je suis très
résistante chien bussereau vosgien donc
la douleur ne m'atteint pas beaucoup
mais il tirait doit à 10,1
dehors il certain peut avoir un peu plus
mal enfin souffler pour être beau voilà
certes j'aime au départ mais quand même
ça serait améliorée voilà je passé un
super moment en tout cas grâce à en
individuel voilà voyez moi beaucoup moi
mais quand même pas mal
la nuit on entendait la veille chez top
pour sortir et j'ai passé un super si
j'en ferai une vidéo demain mais
franchement je suis ravi de charlie leur
part demain demandé dimanche à la haye
lundi chatté pmp en france du plateau
voilà pour faire le point comme d'hab
mais
tous
ils disent lésés mais moi j'aime
beaucoup ses très sincères j'étais dans
sa vidéo youtube m'a permis de
comprendre c'est que justement jeu
télévisé on peut penser qu'ils sont
idiots et depuis quels étaient les
réseaux et ben je me rends compte qu'ils
ne sont pas du tout ils se parlent de
toi
à quelle minute
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mafia
je n'ai pas dave gaudet
mais tu prenais pas à l'export la finma
mais ouais alors direct et j'écoute
écoute je finirai bien fait c'est du
côté de ce droit là voilà les mots de bb
b to b seul alors qu'aucun peut nager
musicaux bien les amis 7h30
voilà émettent en train de tourner un
nouvel inédit dans quelque part normal
la photo et la la c'est guillaume sans
maquillage boumerdès je ne sais jamais
voilà voilà voilà voilà
[Musique]